i've got a
research
research review segment on atp
supplementation are you familiar with
atp greg i've heard of it yeah so if you
open up
literally any book that will make any
mention of biology you will read early
in the book that atp
is the energy currency of the body right
or the energy currency of the cell
so
when we talk about energy in a
physiological context a lot of times we
talk about
you know especially in the nutrition
world we talk about carb and fat and
protein and calories and things like
that
and that's all good but ultimately in
order to do stuff in the body that
requires energy we got to break that
stuff down into atp and that basically
is
a huge uh
a huge portion of what we call
metabolism it's just figuring out how do
we get from these ingested calories down
to atp to do a bunch of stuff in the
body
um now
atp does
a lot of things you know it's
like i said it's the currency it's it's
the thing that's being exchanged when
you're talking about processes that
require energy
but
atp is very critical for muscle
contractions and this is why it gets so
much attention uh in the fitness world
so when muscles are contracting there
are a lot of processes that obviously
require energy
we need to be pumping calcium all over
the place we need to be pumping
sodium and potassium
we need to be helping the myosin head
release itself from actin
and so atp is involved in all of these
energetic processes of muscle
contraction so the concept which sounds
very nice on paper is
it'd be really great if we could provide
some extra atp for our body
via direct oral supplementation you know
if if exercise requires so much atp and
it's so important for muscle contraction
then when we're lifting weights it seems
like it'd be really nice to have some
extra atp around so this is something
that has been studied
you know over the last 15 or 20 years or
so
on a number of occasions and so what i
want to do in this segment is talk about
kind of the historical context of atp
supplements and you know atp boosting
supplements and and then kind of tie
that into a recent study that came out
just this year
uh so back in 2004
there was a study by jordan and
colleagues
and they were looking at atp
supplementation they dosed it at 150
milligrams and also they dosed it at 225
milligrams to see if one or the other or
both might be more favorable than a
placebo
they basically found no significant
benefits when they were comparing these
different these different groups so they
had nine subjects per group
there were some little within group
changes so like oh from before to after
supplementation in this group we saw a
significant increase but at the end of
the day in a placebo-controlled
randomized controlled trial like this
what you're trying to identify is
relative to placebo did these different
doses of the supplement significantly
outperform that placebo treatment so in
this case um you know there were enough
of those little within group differences
to get people
interested but at the end of the day a
rigorous kind of by-the-book
interpretation of the stats would
indicate that there was no significant
benefit beyond that of a placebo
and even within some of those little
within group changes you have to be
really careful just based on some of the
details of the methods i i think they
did a really nice job with the study so
i don't want to sound overly critical
but
um you know there were some very obvious
outliers they did a really nice job
reporting some of those individual level
changes so like in one case i'm pretty
sure single dose supplementation for one
person added like
over 28 kilograms to their chest press
um and that was really just
i would i would speculate
has something to do with the fact that
the chest press increments were not very
small so it was like you could move up
one plate or two or three plates it was
like a machine based kind of deal
that of course wouldn't alone explain it
but also just sometimes you come in you
have a crappy day or sometimes you're
just really unfamiliar with chest
pressing and after a few sessions it
goes up by
a tremendous amount right but
rest assured no one is taking an atp
supplement and saying you know what i
feel 30 kilograms stronger on my bench
right now that's not going to happen so
this was a study you know it served its
purpose as kind of the first study that
i'm aware of in this area that kind of
set the stage for future studies to kind
of build upon um but
herda and colleagues came in
2008 with a purported atp boosting
supplement and once again
supplementation did not lead to any
really exciting differences between
groups uh one thing i forgot to mention
in the jordan study from 2004 probably
one of the most important things from
that study good thing i glossed over it
yeah i i was wondering if uh
if there was going to be some sort of
like big twist reveal at the end no
let's get let's get all the cards on the
table so
the supplement in the jordan study
whether it was given at 150 milligrams
of atp or 225 it did not increase blood
atp levels
and it was really great that they
checked in that study but obviously
that's something that really sets the
stage for major limitations in future
research where you're like
well if an atp supplement is not
increasing circulating atp levels at
least based on you know plasma or crm
measurements
what might be going on here if a
supplement did work right so jordan in
2004
no real significant benefits herda in
2008 no real significant benefits
and then there was a study by lowry and
colleagues actually a series of studies
by lowry and colleagues all coming out
of jacob wilson's lab down at the
university of tampa this was a series of
studies where they looked at different
combinations of atp and hmb
supplementation sometimes both of them
together
and this series of studies i'm just kind
of going to
hit the highlights of it like i'm not
going to go in into really
deep depth about the various
methodological details because
this series of studies uh received very
considerable interest from the
scientific community um you know it
received at least one letter to the
editor this group of studies that raised
some questions about the results and and
things that appeared to be
inconsistencies from study to study um
one of the things that really got a lot
of attention um and various blog posts
and articles covered this
the reported effects from different
combinations of atp and hmb
were
very comparable in magnitude to just
straight up using steroids because there
are studies on
using steroids and lifting weights uh
controlled studies and so
um
there was a lot of back and forth about
that at face you know on the surface it
seemed quite implausible that atp and
hmb would have this kind of effect
because both had been studied previously
and had never done that type of thing
and then you dig deeper and it seems
even more implausible yeah
and you know i remember one of the
things that came up i saw a lot of
people say well no it's just there was
this really hard training program and
that's why it did this thing but like
the placebo group also did the training
program yeah and had very
you know fairly typical placebo group
type gains
and so
that would kind of necessarily imply
that like
the training details don't even really
matter unless you're throwing the good
stuff in there with the hmb and the atp
like
so yeah there was just a lot of stuff
that came up that seemed relatively
implausible
a lot of scientists um
you know kind of
echoed that that um skepticism about
these studies there were letters to the
editor and and so that's kind of uh
where i leave it with that particular
series of studies but uh there's been
another kind of wave of atp
studies coming out so
defritus and colleagues in 2019
they had subjects taking oral atp
supplements at a dose of 400 milligrams
and they ended up completing
significantly greater volume load
across four sets of half squats and this
was you know in comparison to a placebo
treatment so in that study it looked
like okay for some reason
and again the mechanisms really aren't
very clear
it appeared that atp given at 400
milligrams was helping people complete
greater volume load in their training so
maybe this would be a nice training aid
that helps you complete more volume per
session per training block and and
potentially would uh facilitate better
longitudinal adaptations to training and
that is a leap
going from acute effects on training
volume to longitudinal effects on
training adaptations but that would be
the thought process there so helms
actually reviewed that study in mass and
he did a really nice job summarizing all
of this atp literature up to that point
and helms you know came into it with an
open mind and basically concluded based
on the evidence you know
maybe atp supplementation
could possibly enhance performance but
if it did
it appeared at that point specifically
that it would help in circumstances
where you're doing you know multiple
sets taken to failure or multiple sets
with short rest periods it's about kind
of attenuating some of that fatigue in
higher volume sessions where fatigue is
really ramping up between sets
uh however that that was his kind of um
you know that was his like
maybe there could be something in these
scenarios but he also
uh concluded that based on the
inconsistent findings in the literature
uh and the uncertainty related to the
actual mechanism by which atp
supplementation would work
he advised readers to hold off on atp
supplementation until more conclusive
research became available so
he's like maybe it could kind of work in
some of these scenarios but we don't
know why and the research seems to be
really inconsistent so probably not a
safe bet with atp supplements
now there was a new study by dos santos
nunez de mora and colleagues in 2021 i
actually reviewed it as a research brief
uh in the mass research review that went
up today february 1st
so this study had 20 recreationally
trained male participants it was a
crossover design so each participant
completed all four of the study
conditions and the conditions were
either a placebo 100 milligrams of atp
200 milligrams of atp or 400 milligrams
of atp
and in all cases they were ingested 30
minutes prior to exercise testing so
they were doing four sets of barbell
half squats
squatting to about 90 degree knee angle
and they were using a load of 80 percent
of one rep max to
two minutes of rest between sets
so in terms of the findings uh the 400
milligram atp dose appeared to
significantly increase the number of
reps completed in set one okay
but
this was not there were no significant
effects with the lower doses
and also none of the atp doses led to
significantly greater
total reps or total volume when you look
across all four sets
so what's really important about that
is that you know dr helms
the good doctor eric helms tentatively
said okay maybe atp could do something
but based on the literature it should
have its biggest impact potentially
if you're doing multiple set performance
theoretically to failure it should be in
the later sets when it's
attenuating this fatigue that we really
see atp shining as a supplement in this
case it only appeared to matter in the
first set which kind of goes against
that
that rationale
and also i think
you would have to question the utility
of a supplement you know if you were to
take a supplement and you're doing a you
know 16 set workout and it's like this
will help you do more reps
on set number one
but but not two through 16 and not total
you know it's not going to favorably
impact your total training volume in the
session
i would very
strongly question the utility of that
type of supplement if that's
representative of the true effects right
um
and so yet again we find ourselves in a
situation with atp supplementation where
when we look at the applied research and
we say okay what is a dose that should
work and in what circumstances should it
do some predictable thing related to
physiology we still have a lot of
ambiguity and a lot of inconsistency so
every time a study like this comes out
some people who are more
uh supplement friendly are very quick to
pick it up and say hey looks like atp
actually works now let's go ahead and
supplement with it i'm still quite
skeptical
for two main reasons first of course is
the inconsistency related to the applied
findings but the second one that we
really can't overlook
is that i really struggle to identify a
mechanism that seems
both plausible
and optimally targeted by atp
supplementation so
the two most common mechanisms you'll
see there
the first one is just very generally
increasing atp availability during
exercise like hey exercise requires atp
here's some more atp
the second mechanism you hear about a
lot is potentially
atp supplements increasing blood flow
via vasodilation so the idea is that red
blood cells kind of take up this atp and
that's why we're not seeing it increase
in like plasma
after oral supplementation and then
during exercise those
red blood cells are are kind of letting
go of that atp and helping promote
vasodilation during exercise
so the first
issue is with the atp availability one
so like
i was reading through a textbook and
this is really these numbers are really
baffling but
based on the textbook i was reading i
didn't bother to go in and recalculate
stuff so
uh
the human body based on the textbook
uses 40 kilograms of atp per day at rest
that's crazy i did i did not realize it
was that much yeah so again i didn't
bother to go through and recalculate but
somebody let this into a textbook
and i don't know seems fine for me but
40 kilograms of atp per day at rest and
during intense exercise uh the textbook
indicated that atp utilization can reach
up to 0.5 kilograms per minute when
you're doing like really intense
continuous exercise
so
if we take those numbers at face value
and assume that they're even within the
ballpark of being close to true
the idea that you're going to introduce
400 more milligrams so like
0.4 grams of atp
into exercise and actually do anything
with it you know anything beyond just a
drop in a bucket
it's just really implausible to think
yeah just to make the uh
just to make the math easier if we say
it's 500 milligrams yeah that would be
enough to cover
1 1000th of your atp needs per minute
during intense exercise
right and so which doesn't seem like
much yeah and and so if you're hearing
that you're saying well okay but that's
for 400 or 500 milligrams let's really
ramp it up the the human dose lift the
most baby exactly yeah so the human body
can only store about 80 to 100 grams of
atp at a time that's one of the reasons
that it's so important for us to be
continuously generating it is because we
can't just
have like a 40 kilogram
flap where we keep all of our atp that
we're gonna need for the day so um yeah
so like we need to constantly be
creating it throwing 400 milligrams into
the sea of atp
it's a drop in the bucket it's really
not going to matter so then the other
the other issue is through the whole
idea that
the red blood cells are taking it up and
and eventually they're helping to
promote blood flow via vasodilation and
things like that
so
during exercise red blood cells do
release a little bit of atp this is part
of what promotes localized vasodilation
there's
really a lot of stuff going on during
exercise that manages vasodilation and
vasoconstriction during exercise
especially locally there are many many
things happening to make sure that the
muscle is getting sufficient blood flow
to do the exercise it needs to do also a
lot of control going on to make sure
that
blood is circulating appropriately so
that we don't have insane fluctuations
in blood pressure and and you know uh
cardiac output and things like that so
this is a finely tuned response
um now
there are conditions where you might see
that uh
atp released from red blood cells is
reduced and so this could potentially
attenuate vasodilation during conditions
of exercise or conditions of hypoxia so
it is possible that
attenuating atp released from red blood
cells could be problematic in maximally
facilitating this vasodilation however
this is generally seen in older
sedentary people in experimental
conditions so we don't usually see this
kind of impaired atp released from red
blood cells in young healthy people we
also see that this impairment that kind
of occurs with age is attenuated very
considerably in older athletes so the
idea that we're seeing these huge
effects of atp supplementation in young
healthy active people
i think it's relatively implausible
based on this particular mechanism and
everything that comes with it
so
i'm just not there yet with atp
supplements i don't think the applied
research is consistent enough for me
personally
i don't think the mechanisms are very
clearly elucidated we know that plasma
kind of circulating atp is not
increasing to
a noticeable degree
when it's provided as a supplement
uh perhaps red blood cells are taking it
up for for later use but i'm just not
seeing a clear mechanism that would
explain uh some of the applied findings
that have been observed doesn't mean
that atp could not possibly do anything
it's just the research really isn't
there yet to give you a really strong
basis for what it's doing and how it's
doing it so
one of my things that i want to focus on
moving forward is not just shooting down
ideas but also trying to
make sure i'm giving good alternatives
and being maximally helpful
so
let's say that you found some of those
mechanisms to be interesting
atp availability and vasodilation
one of the reasons that i really see atp
supplementation as a non-starter is
because we already have really good
supplements for both of those things so
if you're really interested in
maximizing atp availability during
exercise i can think of no greater
supplement than creatine monohydrate oh
i thought you were going to say epo
well
supplement
supplement
so uh creatine monohydrate like you know
we talked about the
amount of atp that you need relative to
the dose provided it just doesn't make
any sense physiologically it's a drop in
the bucket when we supplement with
creatine monohydrate we can increase our
total creatine concentration in muscle
by you know up to 15 to 30 percent if
we're a responder to creatine and we can
increase phospho-creatine resynthesis by
up to 20 to 50 percent these are real
big physiologically relevant changes in
the phosphagen energy system that
provides atp during intense exercise so
if you're really intrigued in thinking
oh i'd like to use a supplement that
increases atp availability during
exercise
go with creatine it's tried and true
there's a million studies on it if you
want more vasodilation this is something
we've talked about a million times
before
uh
four to six grams of citrulline and or
400 to 800 milligrams of dietary nitrate
it's an extremely straightforward
mechanism by which these supplements
would facilitate vasodilation if there's
any impairment of vasodilation occurring
so you look at
some of the studies in younger healthy
individuals and sometimes you don't see
a big effect on vasodilation with these
supplements
in some cases it still improves
performance without meaningfully
affecting vasodilation through other
mechanisms but when you look in
situations where vasodilation might be
impaired particularly studies with older
individuals who are sedentary these
supplements do a really nice job with
with promoting vasodilation so it's not
just that the atp research is
inconsistent it's that
it looks like it's filling a potential
role here that is already taken care of
by supplements with much more research
supporting them so
uh for those reasons i'm still very
skeptical of atp supplements and that's
not to disparage any of the individuals
doing research in this area i'm just
really skeptical by nature so i need a
lot of evidence to convince me to open
up my wallet or to convince me to
recommend a supplement i haven't seen it
yet with atp and it's going to take not
just you know one more study showing a
few more bench press reps i need someone
to really show me how it's working and
somehow convinced me to believe that
it's doing these things better than the
supplements that are already available
you know so for me to go with atp over
creatine and a more established
vasodilator i'm just not even close yeah
and just to spell things out more with
the with the creatine comparison one of
the reasons that creatine would be a
preferable supplement to something like
atp even if atp worked is
you know let's say you take some atp it
increases muscle concentration of atp uh
one time you do a set you kind of
deplete that and then you're just back
on the the normal atp re-synthesis
treadmill
um whereas with creatine what what
creatine itself does is like it's a
little thing that phosphosphates can
latch onto and then as you deplete atp
during exercise it's a lot quicker to
just kind of take a phosphate from
creatine phosphate and move it over to
an adp to make it an atp again
so that that's a very
quick and efficient little little swap
you can do and then that creatine is
still hanging out in the muscle so
uh you know you finish a set you rest
take some time breathe kind of get back
towards energetic baseline and you can
attach more phosphates to that creatine
that is still in your muscles so
basically with atp it would just be kind
of a one-time use thing whereas higher
creatine concentrations in your muscles
could improve performance you know every
single set over time yeah and that
that's a really good addition because it
contextualizes one of the numbers that i
shared some of the earliest studies on
creatine we're looking at
you know in responders
how much are we actually facilitating
that process that that re-synthesis of
phospho-creatine where the creatine
during rest periods is taking up all of
those phosphates so that it can then
very quickly you know contribute to more
atp production and in responders we're
talking about a 20 to 50 percent
increase in the rate of that
phospho-creatine resynthesis so it is a
noteworthy physiologically meaningful
impact there so with atp supplementation
like i said um it's fascinating i i like
the physiology behind it i think atp if
you like physiology you have to think
atp is interesting because like that
like i said there that's what metabolism
is you're spending most your time
talking about atp
um but yeah i'm just not really there
yet with with atp supplements and i
think there are better options on the
market uh hopefully we'll learn more
about atp in the future but uh for now i
i'd personally say skip it
yeah i mean my uh
my slightly less charitable read of the
literature so actually actually i've got
a question for you okay the 2019 and
2021
studies on atp supplementation uh do you
remember right off the top of your head
if they were industry funded or not
uh i know the 2021
paper was industry funded i don't know
the 2019 paper off the top of my head so
the
like just looking at those results the
first thing that comes to mind for me
is that i know
that
one of one of the companies that sells
an atp supplement is pretty active in in
funding research
and
just looking at some of the differences
especially in that 2021 study that were
there
like you know
you you have four sets you only find a
significant difference in one of them uh
the difference like the raw difference
is 1.2 reps and the p value is 0.04
and you know there's four other
opportunities to find significant
differences the other three sets and
then overall volume
and they didn't find that you know but
they still found one significant
difference paper gets published to me
that
smells a lot like the the tactic of just
like
industry funding studies and then just
kind of picking and choosing
which experiments they want to get
published or not um
you know so it it makes me wonder if
there are also a lot of recent null
results that are just kind of sitting
around unpublished somewhere
um
and and to be clear like that's that's
not taking shots at the researchers
themselves like that's a that's a
relatively
common uh approach for for industry
funding to take
but yeah just looking at those results
it it looks like what i would expect
if that strategy were being employed by
industry
yeah i mean you know my thing is i i
don't
i know you're not doing this but i i
don't try to you know get into the
intentions of what might be going on
behind the scenes or anything like that
um i'm just you know looking at the data
i would assume that there are probably
some acute studies on atp
supplementation that are just sitting in
a
file cabinet that didn't get published
of the stuff that has been published one
of the reasons i don't i haven't dug too
deeply into the behind-the-scenes kind
of considerations is there's not even
enough out here
in the open to even say like yeah yeah
oh yeah you should definitely be you
know if there were i mean we might know
10 years down the line a meta-analysis
gets published and there's just the
wonkiest looking funnel plot you've ever
seen yeah yeah but yeah there's not even
enough now to
to get an idea of that yeah and also
just not enough to
um not enough to make me so like for
example if there was a study that came
or a supplement that hit the market
and there's like nine studies
even six studies showing considerable
meaningful benefits and it's consistent
there's a mechanism identified uh you
know the effects look the way you would
expect if that mecha mechanism was
working consistently you know if if that
were the case but all the studies were
coming from this one group with this one
funding source who owns the supplement
then you start to say wait a minute
there's a lot of positive data out here
but i'm getting a little uneasy about it
in this case there's not even really
enough positive data to bother digging
into the deep stuff because if someone's
saying like hey i really want to take it
i'm like i don't really know why like i
just don't see enough positive data out
in the open to even bother worrying
about what's going on behind the scenes
you know yeah that's fair